if I buy a brick it was 36 o i take that
one brick put some cut on it and turn it
into two and a half brick what are you
cutting there with uh manot who who's
doing that you me you're actually doing
my own process the manat was a
neutralizer sweetener so it didn't do
nothing to you so my drugs was actually
weak but unle say he snorted some mine
and went and took a p test the next day
with in a probation officer and he was
F your Coke doesn't even show up on the
I cut my drill so
bad he thought he was going to go to
jail he said and the lady say
everything's fine he said man you're
good like I am he said my nephew ain't
nothing they hat my nephew stash ain't
[__] Ain nothing